[Applaudissements]
c'est comme c'est quand tu reçois ton
pote de l'école
c'est des bombes à eau
ou ta première meuf
avec
bah oui parce que tu es encore marié
avec elle parle oh là là
tu es un connard non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bien sûr de temps en temps il va un
petit peu loin mais il est connu pour ça
fougasse c'est une fougasse
je l'ai réellement pardon
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà venu me voir deux fois
bizarre calme-toi c'est le dernier jour
de promo c'est pas le moment de
commencer à sortir des conneries
on est sous non mais je vous jure que
quand on se voit c'est vrai
moi je peux vous réconcilier durablement
parce que Michael c'est peut-être pas
mais tout à l'heure quand il est sorti
du plateau vous l'avez rendu un vibrant
hommage voilà j'ai demandé à la Régie
s'ils avaient des images et les ont
malheureusement pour vous Cyril je vous
aime beaucoup mais là je crois que je
vais vraiment la merde dans le
couple
c'est un hommage
les plus pouvoir rien faire
si tu as dit un truc combien c'est quoi
c'est un plasma
arrête avec ça oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je la mémoire je la mémoire
[Rires]
vous l'avez touché
école le bien sur l'oreille
et moi je mets l'oreillette je mets
l'oreillette
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que tu as remarqué comme elle
glisse mieux
crevettes
c'est génial est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on peut y aller
[Rires]
on va finir on va sortir des grosses
conneries calme-toi calme-toi
ça va